tres semanas después de haber comenzado
la invasión rusa a ucrania y de que poco
a poco las ciudades se fueron
movilizando para su defensa en este
puerto de odessa siguen habiendo grupos
de voluntarios que vienen todos los días
hasta la playa a llenar estos bultos con
arena que luego son puestos en estos
camiones y llevados hacia diferentes
partes no solamente de odessa capital
sino de los pueblos de la provincia
hemos visto como estos bultos sirven
para proteger monumentos para crear
barreras en las calles principales pero
estas personas nos dicen que no
solamente se dedican a esto hay grupos
especialmente en facebook donde cada uno
de ellos se inscribe y también trabajan
por ejemplo en recolectando ropa
recolectando medicinas y no solamente
para la población más vulnerable sino
para todos aquellos que están
defendiendo el país como los defensores
de territoriales o el mismo ejército
crean camiones y se los mandan al frente
de batalla esto es bien antes porque a
medida que pasan los días la atención
sigue en odessa es uno de los objetivos
del ejército ruso se habla de una
invasión especialmente por el mar un
desembarco marítimo y también un arribo
de las tropas que vienen por el este sin
embargo pasan los días y a pesar de que
suenan las sirenas y hay alarmas aquí no
ha habido todavía bombardeos y por eso
la gente se pregunta cuándo llegará el
día y si va a llegar